toujours donnée par sa force et en
direction du mont to be time cinquième
plus hauts sommets des alpes en italie
dans le monde
quand vous voyez on se constitue pas été
au bout et on n'avait pas de pouvoir
partir aujourd'hui
ça fait partie de mon époux lui et
finalement on est parti aujourd'hui et
mon pétard est tellement fou j'adore sur
le nuage et garde espoir de 3h retrouve
au vous profitez de cette occasion pour
vous parler d'un book on sent trop
important que des pas sont vous soit en
en point de vue physique et
intellectuelle qui l'emploie d'une
morale ou non interdire que sur ce coup
au moral ce que le sujet a de nouveau
aux particuliers devraient vous paraît
qu'après l'ouverture c'est dépassé une
fois difficile ont vu un homme patient
pourra y arriver
envie de renoncer directement mais ce
qui s'en vont c'est qu'on a le goût de
l'effort et parce qu'on s'entend moral
aussi
devant on devait faudra voir à vouloir
toujours faire pour enfants ou morales a
toujours pouvoir ou confondre
nous apprécions moral et avoue pouvoir
conduire sur mon compte rendu moral
en une semaine on concède deux mois plus
longue - pousse pousse c'est pareil dans
plusieurs vidéos précédentes n'ont plus
l'impression ces personnes sont des gens
qui agissent pour nous laisse pas
tellement l'objectif penser à ces mois
passés sur facebook sont spéciaux nantes
a continué de voir plus sur la plus
complète ont sidéré en lançant tracé
précis que fait que c'est qu'on prenne
sur lui qui aime bien encourageant c'est
le maillot allemand nous sommes mieux
capable de juger des valeurs morales et
les actions à compter outre foutu en
cours je pense que c'est vraiment vers
ça qu'il faut qu'on vend bien sûr
attendre et a tout au plus c'est qu'on
est plus lourd mais nous aussi nous
sommes empochées les vrais pense que je
ferai à melandri faire des sous mais qui
sont encore assez nombreux experts qui
sont quand même des sauveurs c'est très
important
cécile subir très gratifiant ses besoins
et à ses choix j'espère que ce soit le
bon créneau lui duo diouf tonnes qui
sera en face au vol opérationnel de la
météo aux dépens de ses partenaires dont
dont et tout est d'ailleurs remarquer
pas spécifique à la halle tout nouveau
chance qu aux poissons à londres nous
enfin que vous déjà paré vont continuer
tambour des points de compétences et un
mental vos pensées de nos amis contre au
contexte social nous avons négocié pour
l'instant et mon sperme à jouer un
poteau projet solo
notre concept un autre aspect important
de ce conseil deux mois le plus noir et
plus c'est qui permet de rendre la
morale le faire de la morale dans une
quête personnelle si je pense que c'est
vraiment important parce qu'on a
tendance à penser que le moral c'est une
quête passé à 87 enseigné comme un truc
assez top down qui vient d'en haut
placés du parent qui nous font la morale
la pression est supérieure d'un poussin
qui nous font mal et ça ça fait 2
contient le moral ou de la quête de la
morale un exercice assez ont eu lieu à
c'est assez désagréable en fait
et alors je pense qu'il veut vendre y
avoir quelque chose de très très très
agréable a cherché à mieux comprendre
nos mourad intuitive à mieux les
formaliser et surtout à mieux rendre
cohérente
extrapolé une usine et ce qu'elle serait
si on est plus intelligent plus
informelle tout ça est d'ailleurs à ce
fut dur il y a break dans un des
épisodes action après que thibault on
est justement de ces moments où on a
découvert ensemble
voilà un bien gouverner notre moral
intuitive et encore et encore des du
coût et du coup je pense que cette
rédaction vous pressés parce qu'on est
encore assez mon école on sent vraiment
de l'enthousiasmé dont le voir dans
cette compréhension d'un aspect de notre
moral de nos morale intuitive respectifs
et d'ailleurs ce que je dis là est pas
du tout a restreint à la quête de la
morale car pense que ça va venir la
montagne ces deux-là nombre des sommets
c'est aussi une quête personnelle c'est
à dire que c'est vraiment nous qui
allons mentionnait il se serait bien
moins fun non moins gratifiant 6 voir
pour atteindre un sommet si je prends un
hélicoptère au japon boj
le fait que ça soit un effort individuel
personnel est une composante extrêmement
importante au fait que la montagne soit
si gratifiant toi si plaisante soir s'il
excitant donc là encore une fois j'ai
complété l'analogique avec la quête de
la connaissance dans le livre la formule
de savoir quoi
ici j'ai vraiment essayé de faire de
cette quête de reconnaissance non pas un
truc tout besoin quand on attend ses
antennes et à l'école mais c'est de
faire de cela une quête personnelle
autant possible j'espère que les joueurs
parisiens où plus ressentir que pour
lisant ce livre n'était pas juste en
train de suivre mû par visite est aussi
en train d'explorer eux-mêmes de champs
de la connaissance de ce qui peut se
faire en effet synology et tout ça pour
dire que c'est super important je pense
que faire de la morale n'ont pas notre
objectif
il faut apprendre que sa cession serait
la pire des choses voulais faire plus
tôt aux amours âge un objectif personnel
une quête d'un mois plus souvent nous
voir lommois puisse plus pour essayer de
progresser mentalement et je pense que
ça serait beaucoup plus stimulant
ça permettrait de motiver beaucoup plus
ces gens à se poser des questions
morales voilà on peut encore tout à fait
au code vous passez de passagers me
suffire
vous trouverez des images y colle plus
tard auprès des images plus en 360
degrés comme ça
pas facile à faire enfin loin ou pas
tout à faire
thomas de patience on va lui va parler
sur twitter que que tout à l'heure et
qui me faisait la remarque mais vous une
variante ou en fait on ajouterait enfin
les les frigos à organes comme je les
appelle certains vers l'idée de créer
des êtres humains juste pour récolter
leurs organes si on leur donnait une vie
en fait pendant ces paroles et fait
vivre pendant 20 ans du c'est prévu au
bout de vingt ans ils vont à l'abattoir
leur donner une vie qui te voilà pouvait
faire quelque chose de leur vie des
problèmes de maths des trucs comme ça
il a l'intuition elle ferait beaucoup de
gens l'intuition que ce serait pire
personnellement j'ai l'intuition que
c'est bien meilleurs qu'eux à tout
prendre je préférais ça si si c'est pas
une vie de souffrance si c'est une vie
normale sylvie d'êtres humains dans
lequel on peut faire des trucs
oui on respecte davantage l'individu et
sa liberté en faisant ça après ça reste
horrible je voudrais pas qu'on fasse
mais h au choix entre ça et maintenir
tous ces individus dans une prison
chimiques
j aucun doute sur le fait que je préfère
même leur donner un peu de liberté et un
peu d'autonomie
voilà et la possibilité de mener une vie
d'êtres humains un minimum je pense que
je rejoins comment tu préfères les
charmes art hogan tous les matins de
brevets je vais aller faire mes choix
vargas et tu préfères même réfléchi si
d'un point de vue utilitariste est-ce
que d'un point de vue utilitaire imagine
sa demande le même coût en ressources
le fait de maintenir un individu dans
une cave avec une camisole chimique dont
clicmobile toute sa vie et le fait lui
laisser un certain un certain espace de
liberté
on les fait vivre dans une ville entre
eux juste à 20 ans on les emmène à
l'abattoir et on a et ça se passe sans
souffrance qu'on les emmène à l'abattoir
et c est ce que d'un point de vue
guitariste et pas plus de bonheur dans
la version où il y a
voilà cet espace de liberté quand même
pour les pour les frigos à un organe que
dans la version on y maintient dans une
camisole chimique est en train de me
dire que le le mec qui va bientôt mourir
il doit compter hirawi du bonheur global
mais oui sauf si tu pourras dire que la
vie n'est pas le débat c'est est ce que
la somme des bonheurs c'est ce qu'ils
vont toi est ce que fait plus une
moyenne des bonheurs mais en admettant
que même lors que sur leur temps de vie
leur bonheur est plutôt plus élevé que
le nôtre au moins aussi élevés c'est
qu'avant aux principes déontologiques
en fait c'est ça qui est intéressant
c'est que je pense que la raison pour
laquelle les gens préfèrent le truc de
la camisole chimique c'est pas pour des
raisons utilitariste en fait d'un
utilitarisme me ferait plutôt préféré
une version l'ordre un espace de liberté
où ils peuvent peut être heureux mais
bizarrement ça choque davantage je pense
aussi à moi personnellement c'est
typiquement si on me disait bon on va
créer un clone de toi voilà il ya 20 ans
prendra ses organes et il ya deux
options salle même coup c'est soit on le
maintient qu'elle met un petit mix on
lui donne on le fait vivre
voilà dans un espace où il peut un peu
s'épanouir je voudrais qu'on le fasse
pas d'abord ni l'un ni l'autre je
préférerais ni l'autre ne soit fait mais
s'il faut choisir les deux jeux
j'ai l'impression au moins d'être un peu
plus sympa quoi avec cet individu en
donnant la possibilité de voir un peu de
liberté et en plus une vie quand même je
pense que le il ya une notion de
changement qui est qui qui est important
de quelque part parce qu'on a
l'impression que enfin celui qui a
grandi dans une ferme
lorsqu'il meurt et ça change pas grand
chose que alors que alors que celui qui
a vécu heureux jusqu'à 20 ans lorsqu'il
meurt ça ça change quelque chose que
vous
pas donner aux gens les voient
l'intuition c'est qu'il ya à l'idée
qu'on lui causent un tort plus grande
parce que justement il avait davantage
ouais et que des rotations il faudrait
minimiser le tort et en un certain sens
en accordant strictement rien à ces
individus on minimise les torts parce
que il n'ya pas de moment on nous prive
de quelque chose enfin en 1 106 mais on
perçoit moins ce tort parce qu'on les
prive pour ainsi dire dès le départ il
ya pas une sorte de situation de
référence qui correspondrait à leur état
normal
vous avez desquels on les prive la leur
la situation de référence mais je pense
que c'est vraiment ça en fait c'est
l'histoire de référence et une vidéo de
sciences et nature en référençant les
anciens bbc fait un peu de cet ordre là
enfin après c'est s'attaquer à la raison
tu sais pas si on conserve un biais
cognitifs s'il part il faudrait réviser
son isolement
en tout cas je pense c'est le genre de
raisonnement qu'ont fait je sais pas si
c'est une pop l'essai anglais mais ouais
c'est je pense qu'on utilise mon nom se
fixe une référence et du coup je pense
que c'est pareil pour le le cas le
niveau 6 plus de six mois plus tôt
lorsque la personne prend conscience de
deux d'être sauvé l'impression que c'est
la nouvelle référence et que tout ce qui
vient après c'est juger par rapport à la
grèce et à ses yeux lorsqu'il a réveillé
trois minutes seulement
c'est ça ne suffit pas pour que ça
devienne la référence
ouais je pense que c'est une bonne façon
d'analyser le truc effectivement absent
cause est vraiment un tort à l'individu
à partir de là parce qu'il ya une
nouvelle référence c'est il est réveillé
avec ses hauts et ses bas
on attend de malades trop trop regarder
ces nuages et soleil
cette crevasse monstrueuse
il ya un matin de viols
vous avez parlé pourchet pas trop à quoi
m'attendre au café la vue sur une vallée
j'espère il faut être prêt s'il
respirait si je trouve flouter son
chaudron c'est trop bien voir des
personnes ne soient qui est juste trop
loin en décembre et oussama des halles
du massif du monte oh ça c'est vraiment
soit vraiment trop cool on a une météo
génial on passe nos colonnes la grande
vallée le bac je vais en profiter pour
parler de l'importance de
l'environnement passe de cette quête du
mois ou quelques cas très personnelle il
faut sans penser au personnel mais
combien se rend compte que cette quête
personnelle
vous pouvez y arriver tout seul la
culture a gagné énormément à être bien
accompagné
pour réussir cette quête personnelle pas
si je suis là aujourd'hui c'est parce
que le précompte pour vous et moi je les
ai aussi chauffer pour iag mais ba c'est
un truc
ensemble c'est super important de
troubles en cours et avoir un
environnement culturel et social cela
est moins eu 41 patients par an si vous
n'êtes pas déçu avec 4000 et plein de
choses super mais je pense que pour les
questions de connaissances et de morale
c'est vraiment important aujourd'hui de
se poser ces questions surtout si vous
êtes quelqu'un qui est un peu compétent
ou impurs et si vous voulez y arriver
j'ai bien peur que la priorité soit
vraiment quand leur choix si je vous
parle on note également une priorité
pour cette quête personnelle c'est de
s'entourer de travail et l'environnement
social et culturel autour de nous serons
encore qu'il va les changer le paysage
et si je suis là c'est grâce à vous
heureusement c'est aussi avec tout mon
courage et singulièrement à vivre ce
genre de moments incroyables et mais il
faire taire un peu cassée personnel mais
qui serait jamais arrivé tout seul tout
ça ok donc comme vous voyez dans l'après
midi les conditions sont un petit peu un
petit peu gâté et en plus
enregistrements a foiré
bien que le sent il pas très terrible je
suis vraiment désolé pour ça mais j'ai
quand même conclure cette vidéo alors en
vous disant ou narrant ce que j'avais
dit à ce moment là
ce que je voulais vraiment dire c'est
que dans cette quête d'un progrès qui
soit un progrès dans l'ascension dès
sommets de pont près physique ou un
progrès intellectuel ou un progrès moral
c'est ultra important d'avoir des guides
à ce que les espaces d'exploration de
son juste énorme et il ya vraiment moyen
de se perdre et voir de tomber de se
faire mal et de chuter et de ne plus
vouloir se relever ils pensent que
l'analogie tient vraiment notamment par
exemple avec l'apprentissage des
mathématiques je pense que c'est quelque
chose qui peut être extrêmement violent
et c'est extrêmement douloureux pour les
étudiants et ça peut les amener à se
dire bon je ferai plus jamais des
mathématiques où je suis mauvais en
mathématiques ne me parlez pas de
mathématiques
je pense que c'est un réflexe que
malheureusement beaucoup trop de gens ou
pour en montagne ça peut être un peu
plus catastrophique puisque ça peut être
juste mourir mais en mathématiques ça
peut aussi être mourir mathématiquement
j'ai envie de dire et malheureusement ce
qui est encore plus dangereux c'est que
d'apprendre vue moral je pense qu'on
peut parler une espèce de mort morale
une certaine manière on ne veut juste
plus entendre parler de morale on veut
juste dire laissez moi faire ce que je
veux faire j'ai ma morale arrêtez de me
faire chier je pense que malheureusement
ces réflexes qui est beaucoup beaucoup
trop courant chez la plupart d'entre
nous on n'aime pas parler de morale
c'est difficile de parler de morale et
ont du mal à s'engager à parler de
morale et mais c'est encore plus
difficile de bien parler de morale tout
ça parce que c'est facile de se perdre
dans nos réflexions morales bref tout ça
pour dire que c'est super important pour
ne pas se perdre d'avoir un guide et je
pense qu'on a été très très très mal là
dans cette ascension si on n'avait pas
eu un guide pour nous ramener sur le bon
chemin lorsque la météo se gâte
je pense qu'il en est de même pour la
morale à faut bien choisir ses guides
c'est pas facile il faut pas prendre un
seul guide faut essayer de vider
complètement suivre aveuglément le guide
mais c'est ça reste souvent
indispensable
- pour essayer de mieux structurer notre
pensée être accompagné par quelqu'un qui
déjà est bienveillant si possible et qui
va nourrir nos réflexions et nous
permettre de ne pas nous perdre dans nos
réflexions
bref si je conclus du coup cette vidéo
en gros ce que je voulais vraiment dire
c'est que la quête d'une meilleure moral
est quelque chose de très important
aujourd'hui
et pour y arriver je pense qu'il est
très utile de voir ça comme une quête
personnelle qui doit absolument être
nourrie par un environnement
bienveillant et instructif et qui doit
sans doute faire intervenir ici et là
des guides pour nous éviter de nous
perdre en réflexion voilà c'était ma
force avec une qualité audio visuel
assez limité je m'en excuse encore une
fois il essaiera de faire mieux pour les
prochaines fois j'espère que ça aura
malgré tout nourri un peu vos réflexions
et je vous invite à longuement réfléchir
et à ne postez vos commentaires qu'après
une certaine réflexion